officials now say this was an attack on
US soil coordinated with the help of al
Qaeda last December Saudi Arabian cadet
lieutenant mohammed saeed al sham rani
opened fire on the pensacola military
base where he was training leaving three
US service members dead and eight
injured al Qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula initially claimed
responsibility but in a news conference
Monday US officials confirmed that
blaming the many months of delays on
Apple refusing to help them unlock his
phones in the months before the attack
while he was here among us he talked
with AQAP about his plans and tactics
taking advantage of the information he
acquired here to assess how many people
he could try to kill he was meticulous
in his planning he made pocket cam
videos as he cased his classroom
building the US Attorney General also
announced the information led to a
military strike but gave few other
details
indeed the information from the phones
has already proved invaluable in
protecting the American people a
counterterrorism operation targeting
AQAP operative Abdullah al-maliki one of
al-sham Ronnie's overseas associates was
recently conducted in Yemen after the
shooting officials quickly discovered al
sham Ronnie had left many social media
posts that should have raised red flags
but were missed well they tried to put
the focus on the dispute with the
technology companies it's likely that
members of Congress are gonna be asking
more questions about exactly how this
individual was able to have so much
communication with people in Yemen well
being a part of the military training
program with access to sensitive US
military bases patty Fontaine al Jazeera
Washington